er schreit der stirbt diese worte
berühmten terroristen vor 44 jahren
durch einen urlaubsflieger durch die
lufthansa maschine landshut unterwegs
von mallorca eigentlich nach hause doch
aus der urlaubsstimmung wird todesangst
eine entführung terror ein tagelanges
geiseldrama das auf dem wüsten flughafen
von mogadischu endet dank des
spektakulären und mutigen einsatzes
deutscher polizisten
es ist der dreizehnte oktober
1977 nordens meine damen und herren eine
linienmaschine der deutschen lufthansa
ist seit dem nachmittag in der gewalt
von entführern
die lufthansa boeing landshut ist auf
dem weg von palma de mallorca nach
frankfurt an bord 86 passagiere fünf
besatzungsmitglieder und vier
palästinensische terroristen die
anführer der 23-jährige mahmud der
albtraum beginnt fünf tage todesangst
die forderung der entführer die
freilassung von 11 in deutschland
inhaftierten mitgliedern der
linksextremistischen terrorgruppe rote
armee fraktion raf
doch der krisenstab unter helmut schmidt
gibt nicht nach das vorgehen der
terroristen brutal in der maschine
machen die entführer klar wer schreit
stirbt nach einer zwischenlandung in rom
geht es über zypern weiter nach dubai
die maschine wird aufgetankt 54 stunden
verharren sie dort ein geplanter geisel
austausch kommt nicht zustande
die landshut fliegt weiter nach aden im
jemen dort wird pilot jürgen schumann
mit einem gezielten kopfschuss im gang
erschossen und blutend auf die rollbahn
geworfen der co pilot jürgen fiedler
fliegt die maschine alleine weiter nach
mogadischu die terroristen setzten ein
neues ultimatum um die raf mitglieder zu
entlassen sie drohen damit die maschine
zu sprengen und übergießen die
passagiere mit alkohol machen
sprengkörper scharf die bundesregierung
suggeriert den terroristen dass sie
kooperieren will doch dann der zugriff
am 18 oktober um 0 05 stürmt die gsg9
einheit die landshut sieben minuten
dauerte der einsatz drei von vier
geiselnehmern werden erschossen bis auf
kapitän schumann überleben alle geiseln
die hölle von mogadischu aber noch heute
kommen die grausamen erinnerungen zurück
ja diese schrecklichen tage die bleiben
in den köpfen aller deutschen die diese
momente damals am fernseher verfolgt
haben vor allem natürlich in den köpfen
all derer die in dem flugzeug saßen oder
bei der rettungsaktion dabei war die
geiseln die stewardessen die polizisten
sowie gabriele von luther die berühmte
stewardess der land zu die in diesen
tagen das hier bei twitter geschrieben
hat da die sich nämlich noch mal
erinnert hat und geschrieben hat heute
ging es los das wollten wir eigentlich
in diesem moment noch mal zeigen um 18
war alles vorbei also bei jedem
jahrestag immer wieder diese
erinnerungen wie hier von gabriele von
luther und sie haben sie gerade schon
gesehen die berühmt gewordene stewardess
die uns zugeschaltet ist gemeinsam mit
zwei anderen helden aus der landshut aus
mogadischu nämlich peter fox der an der
rettungsaktion so stark beteiligt war
und jana müll die damals eine der
geiseln eine der passagierinnen in der
landshut war in allen herzlich
willkommen bei bild lagen
kann auch von luther ich habe gerade
schon gesagt dass bleibt allen deutschen
für immer im kopf und dabei waren wir
gar nicht dabei aber wie geht es ihnen
vor von nutzer gibt es einen tag an dem
sie nicht daran denken mussten
[Musik]
eigentlich die meisten tage denke ich
nicht mehr daran es ist sehr sehr lange
her ja aber immer werden natürlich der
oktober kommt und da denke ich alleine
schon durch die berichterstattung wieder
dran und am 18 oktober gehe ich immer
bin ich immer mit meinem mann und meinen
kindern essen gegangen und wir haben uns
gefreut dass ich noch da bin
sie haben also das leben gefeiert immer
dann an diesem tag ich aber auch daran
erinnert wie schrecklich die stunden
gewesen sein mögen werden wir hier
sprechen ist weltmeister einmal
unterbrechen haben wir eben gerade
bilder gesehen die möchte ich nur kurz
einordnen die gehören natürlich nicht zu
ihrer geschichte frau von o2 es gehört
zu der geschichte die sich jetzt gerade
live hier in berlin abspielt gerade hat
einen räumpanzer dort auf das gelände
des coupés das beobachten wir hier live
gerichtsvollzieherin stand vor der tür
dort gerade eine angeheizte situation in
der hauptstadt die wir weiterhin nicht
aus dem blick verlieren dann auch wollen
wir reden über die schwierigen stunden
die sie durchmachen mussten die sie ein
leben mussten tagelang das kann man sich
überhaupt nicht vorstellen haben sie da
irgendwann die hoffnung aufgegeben dass
sie da wieder lebens rauskommen folge
haben
ganz kurzfristig habe ich sie aufgegeben
als wir in die luft gesprengt werden
sollten und mit alkohol übergossen
worden da habe ich eigentlich mit meinem
leben abgeschlossen
aber so wie auch nur der hauch einer
chance kam kam die lebensgeister wieder
weg ich bin niemand der aufgibt
für sie frau müll und ich begrüße auch
sie herzlich sie saßen damals eben in
der landshut über diese ganzen tage am
ende auf diesem wüsten flughafen eben
und ihnen wurde vom müll die dass wir
einmal ganz kurz umschalten ist eben
immer noch von nutzer genau vom müll
müsse sie herzlichen wurde damals die
pistole an den kopf gehalten von dem
terroristenanführer von diesem macht mut
und wurde angedroht jetzt rückwärts zu
zählen wenn die maschine nicht voll
getankt wird dieser moment der wird
einem nie nie nie nie aus dem kopf gehen
richtig
da können sie ganz sicher sein da sie
diesen moment in ihrem leben vergessen
es ist natürlich wie die frau lutz auch
schon gesagt hat lange her allerdings
sind das gedanken wenn ich über die
landshut spreche oder wenn ich daran
denke an die entführung dann ist das
immer ein moment wo ich dann an der tür
stehen mich an der tür stehen sie mit
der pistole am kopf her ja das ist ein
einschneidender moment moment und er ist
für das ganze leben
herr c dieser moment verändert wie oft
denken sie da noch dran
also auf jeden fall immer im oktober das
ist ganz klar oder er hat immer wenn ich
darüber berichtet ich bin auch ab und zu
mal an schulen und erzähle über die über
die geschichte der landshut und da kommt
das thema natürlich auch immer wieder
raus
erfolgs auch sie grüße ich herzlich sie
alle sind so sehr verbunden durch diese
gemeinsame unglaubliche geschichte wie
oft erinnern sie sich an genau das was
passiert ist die standen ja sozusagen
auf der anderen seite sind einer der
retter einer der helden dieser terror
aktion
ja wie gerade schon gesagt wurde ist die
oktober für uns alle ist so ein
prägnanter monat der drei zehnter und
dreizehnter begangen ist am 18 eine
offizielle geändert insofern ist da
natürlich schon eine periode die nicht
so einfach vorbei geht
gleichwohl muss man sagen 44 jahre
danach
da hat sich natürlich auch schon einiges
abgespielt auch bei uns
dennoch wenn wir uns mit unseren
kameraden treffen auch einmal das
jahrestreffen dann kommt immer wieder
das eine oder andere hoch was man na ja
diskutiert bespricht zurückdenkt und
nächstes jahr 50 jahre gsg 9 dann wird
natürlich auch wieder eine erinnerung
wach und da wird sicherlich auch das
eine oder andere besprochen herford
lassen sie uns mal auf diesen moment
gehende wo das wunder möglich gemacht
wurde die stimmung köpfe runter wo sind
die schweine haben sie gerufen nachdem
es den großen knall gab wie ging es
ihnen was haben sie gefühlt in diesem
moment als sie da in die maschine
reingegangen sind
wenn man als einsatzkraft einen solchen
einsatz
durchmachen musste und fühlt man
zunächst mal
viel taktik fiel die strategie fiel das
was man vorher ein trainiert hat und
natürlich eine allererster stelle die
menschen die also mehrere tage mehrere
stunden zugebracht haben und gelitten
haben die zu befreien das ist priorität
alles andere ist 1 1 ein trainierter
ablauf und deswegen sind also die
typischen gefühl oder die typischen
emotionen von denen man so spricht die
haben die einsatzkräfte nicht das kommt
hinterher nachdem alles vorbei ist
nachdem auch die spannung runter ist und
dann
statt im körper natürlich auch das eine
oder andere runter und dann tage danach
erinnert man sich vielleicht und es kann
sogar sein dass dann vielleicht
emotionen kommen sie sind und sie
bleiben für immer einer dieser gsg9
einer der mogadischu landshut helden
herr fox und letzte frage ganz kurz an
frau von luther und auch frau müll
fliegen sie eigentlich nach wie vor
fliegen sie
also ich fliege aber jedes mal mit einem
komischen gefühl aber die werden mich
nicht unterkriegen ich fliege trotzdem
weiter
kommen auch sie
sieht das ganz genauso also die
fliegerei und ich wir werden keine
freunde mehr in diesem leben und mit ein
bisschen tabletten und so da krieg ich
das schon hin habe ich fliege auch
weiter obwohl ich damals neun jahre
nicht bewegen bin aber sie lassen sich
alle nicht unterkriegen sie haben sich
alle kriegen lassen über all diese jahre
auch von lutz sie haben diesen jahrestag
erstmals verbracht verbringen müssen
ohne ihren mann lassen sie uns ganz kurz
in ihr herz schauen in diesem tag
das ist mein ganz privates herz
und dies besonders starkes herz wir
danken ihnen sehr sehr herzlich dafür
dass sie sich zeit genommen haben mit
uns über dieses schicksal das sie alle
drei verbindet fünf tage lang und dann
die rettung dass wir darüber mit uns
gesprochen habe und wie ich mich fühlen
herzlichen dank
[Musik]